hi and welcome to another video of I
teach and biological science and
biotechnology question reviews
today's topic is cell signaling after
detailed analysis of previous year
questions I came to a conclusion with
the detailed statistics how many
questions are asked from cell biology
section and here is the result so on an
average every year roughly five
questions are being asked in from this
topic and among that roughly 2 or 1
questions every year is from cell
signaling topic the topic is easy a
highly topic so here are some questions
solution from those topic before we
start I want to let you know that all
the relevant cell signaling concepts
that you need to know for solving these
questions are available in my channel so
go and check my self signaling playlist
and the link is given in the end screen
so here is the first question which is
from I teach and biotechnology 2018 and
this question says which of the
following statement is correct for a
g-protein coupled receptor signaling now
GPCRs contain 7 transmembrane spanning
region definitely it is true
second is gpcr are linked with
heterotrimeric g protein consisting
alpha beta and gamma subunit definitely
it is true in absence of GPCR in absence
of gpcr interacting ligand alpha subunit
of g protein is bound to GTP and
complexed with beta gamma subunit so it
is not true I would explain this concept
in a moment in presence of gpcr
interacting ligand GTP is displayed from
displaced from half a subunit of cheap
protein by GDP and GDP bound to alpha
subunit dissociate from peter gamma
dimer and activates an effector so the
correct answers are a and B and C and D
are not true I would show why they are
not true so here is an overview of G
in signaling screen so you can see when
the ligand binds to the g-protein
coupled receptor which is a seven
transmembrane domain receptor G alpha
subunit is getting activated and it's
gtp GDP one can assign diphosphate is
replaced by gtp and which is activating
hadn't landed cyclase and thus this
further signaling has happened so in an
inactive form G alpha subunit is found
with GDP so it's kind of a switch which
is off in death that state upon ligand
binding one no sign nucleotide exchange
factors or give actually help G alpha
subunit to get converted to GTP bound
confirmation which is an active
conformation or on conformation like
thing and that is reversible by the
action of GTP as activator proteins or
caps upon the same concept another
question was asked in our teacher in
2014 so the binding of hormone to its
receptor activates adenylate cyclase
through a stimulatory g-protein
signaling if due to a mutation the G
protein binds
do the G protein binds but does not
hydrolyze gtp the consequence would be
and the consequence is easy Hadean
hundred cycles would be constitutively
activated and this question has a little
bit twist towards a disease site I would
discuss so normally what happens is when
a ligand mind the G alpha GT b subunit
gets activated and in translocate along
the membrane to activate adenylate
cyclase and the adenylate cyclase
converts ATP to cyclic
ANP so there are a few toxins cholera
toxins who actually modifies the g alpha
subunit by adp ribosylation
and thereby locks it lock it into a
constitutively active state or
constantly on state so this question
says though it doesn't require this
but it says what happens in 10 G alpha
subunit is locked in a GTP state so if
the G alpha subunit is locked in a GTP
state then there won't be lot of cyclic
AMV produced from the ATP because
Admiral it cycles is constitutively
active in this situation and so the next
question is which of the following are
characteristics of receptor level
receptors for soluble hormones they have
a kinase domain the function has a
homodimer
or heterodimer they are mostly located
on cytoplasm or nucleus they are
transcription factor so the correct
options are P C and B and here is the
concept behind it so roughly the nuclear
receptors are having several domains
known as anp2 min which has the
transcription activation function C
domain is the DNA binding and a domain
is the ligand binding and also it has a
transcription activation function second
- and if domain is the cytosolic so it
doesn't have a kinase domain definitely
so the that option is not correct so it
could be either present in the cytosol
and when the ligand binds it translocate
to nucleus in case of steroid hormones
this phenomenon is most common or it
could be the receptors are heterodimer
rising in the nucleus and they are bound
to the gene itself waiting for the
soluble hormone to be there so that kind
of situation is true for thyroid
hormones so they could be either nuclear
or they could be cytosolic and they
could be also homo dimer or hetero
doctor so second next question is
apoptosis is controlled by its a control
cell death process and that process
involves
exposure of phosphatidylserine on the
outer surface of the cell membrane
decrease for mutable permeability of the
mitochondrial membrane increase lysosome
activity inter nucleosomal intern
imprisonment cleavage of the genomic DNA
so the correct options are this one and
also this one is false increase
lysosomal activity is the another
correct option and so internally normal
cleavage of the genomic DNA is correct
so apart from me all the options are
correct and though it's kind of little
bit deviated from this topic so I would
discuss about its concept in some later
videos
now here another video says another
question says that the intracellular
messenger formed by the activation of
hospital in aesthetic cascade are so the
correct option is inositol one four five
tryst phosphate and diacylglycerol
basically high position deg
same question is a game repeated in 2018
so which says which of the following
statements are true about phosphorus in
tight signaling cascade and the correct
options are generation of ip3 is general
generation of ib3 transiently increases
the calcium concentration and calcium 2
plus facilitate the activation of
protein kinase C so here is and another
question is also on the same topic the
cellular organelle which functions as a
store of calcium is it would be into
plasmic reticulum so all these things is
covered in this concept so in case of GQ
signaling G alpha Q upon ligand binding
G alpha Q dissociates and it's activate
phospholipase C
phospholipase C Cleaves the high P 3 and
whatever is left is da G so here is the
concept so pip2 is actually a membrane
bound lipid phospholipase c can cleave
that leave da g hanging on the membrane
and release type III once i p3 is
released it is bound to the store
operated calcium channel
on the endoplasmic reticulum and it
allows the endoplasmic reticulum to like
extrude calcium from endoplasmic
reticulum and thereby Sancho solely
calcium increases from and it comes from
the endoplasmic reticulum and also what
happens when calcium goes out it
actually activates protein kinase C
which further activates several
downstream effectors another question
says the preferred ligand for sh2 domain
is saline phosphorylated peptide or
tyrosine phosphorylated peptide glucose
6-phosphate or cyclic A&P so the answer
is tyrosine phosphorylated peptide so
let me discuss what is sh2 domain and
where it is found so if H - domain is
related to map kinase signaling or other
growth factor signaling and several
proteins has this sh2 domain
one example is adaptor proteins which
bind to phosphotyrosine this attina so
these adaptor proteins here the gr v 2
has safe h2 domain and it binds to the
phosphotyrosine with a CTU of the
phosphorylated receptor tyrosine kinase
so a GRB - or many other protein many
other kinase has this sh2 domain which
can bind to several phosphatidyl
simplicity and here is a 3d structure of
that you can understand that in the
pocket of these grb-2 phosphor serine
residue is inserted so it binds to the
first person University and here is the
few list of some transcription factors
some adapters some enzymes which has sh2
domain and also a similar domain is sh3
domain so if you like my videos give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and stay tuned for
more videos thank you
you